hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Walking Dead Q&A generally a
lot of questions about what's gonna be
happening with Beth as well as the other
people that showed up in the episode
that end credits scene I do have some
theories about how said person ended up
at the hospital I think it's partially
on purpose but episode 6 is when they're
probably gonna explain that so careful
for spoilers from the episode if you're
not cut up yet but here we go
question number one stalking ass when it
comes to paying back what you owe how do
they determine the value of everything I
think largely Don is the one that
determines value it seemed like what
they were implying is is that the more
your word the more you have to pay back
like Don wants to keep people there who
are worth a lot people that serve highly
critical functions that's why the doctor
was so quick to try and get rid of that
other doctor so that he would be higher
value as for what Beth owes I think
that's largely determined on the value
of the medicine that they gave her you
could call it a little bit of commentary
on the healthcare system and that they
gave her very little care but they're
charging her a lot for people that live
in international countries health care
in America is extremely expensive we
don't have universal health care that's
why some people can go bankrupt from
staying in a hospital too long even if
Don is playing it fast and loose with
what she's asking people to pay back or
telling them what they owe I do think
that she has a system in her head she
seems like a fairly analytical person
even if she's operating on false
information like the false hope that
people are gonna come rescue her
question number two vid Leslie asks did
Officer nasty knock Beth out and take
her based on what the other girl was
saying it seemed like the police were
stealing people not saving them yes it
did seem like he was trying to get his
own little harem going
I think they randomly crossed paths but
when he did see her he thought that
she'd make a nice addition so he just
clubbed her and threw her in the back of
the car
so yes I'm firmly coming down on the
side of Beth being kidnapped
question number three Extreme Pro asked
why is Carol at the hospital so there's
a couple of theories so the first one is
is that she and Daryl followed that car
with a cross on it and she infiltrated
the hospital by getting herself hurt the
other theory is is that she and Daryl
got in a fight with them or other people
and then the police found her and
brought her in as for why Daryl is not
there I think that whatever the fight is
that they got in or whatever
their plan was they tried to get away
and Carroll was taken I think it's
really a combination of both those
things I think they took off after that
car they thought took Beth got into a
really sticky situation then Carroll saw
how it was gonna go down and just let it
happen thinking that she might be able
to find bet that way like they were in a
losing situation and she let Daryl get
away just like Beth let Noah get away I
think there'll be some parallels between
Beth Noah Daryl and Carol question
number four a non-key asks do you think
that Morgan is the uncle Noah said he's
looking for I think that would be an
awfully big coincidence but it would be
really cool Scott Gimple was really coy
about Morgan's storyline this season
it's gonna happen separate from everyone
else for at least the most part just
because so many things feel like they're
converging at the hospital for this
mid-season finale I do think that
Morgan's going to come into play so I do
think it'll turn out that he is somehow
connected to the Noah character just
from a storytelling perspective if
you're sitting in the writers room at
Walking Dead and you want people to go
as nuts as possible during the
mid-season finale what would you do
first you'd have a big battle at the
hospital and you bring Morgan back and
full-on right gear with giant weapons
that just feels like something that
they'd want to go out on for the
mid-season break question number five
Dexter asks do you think over the course
of the season Beth will start to be more
like crazy Rick and go nuts on everyone
in the hospital so I think there's two
ways that best or likely go down one she
could toughen up and help herself escape
two she could end up dying or
sacrificing herself for people at the
hospital both of those scenarios are
heroes arcs for her character I think
that's what they have her on right now
like she's slowly becoming just as
valuable as all the other survivors all
the badasses one of them is pretty
straight-up badass hero the other is a
tragic hero storyline so it depends on
how tragic you think Beth's character is
I think we won't learn more about what's
gonna happen with her for a couple more
episodes at least until we follow up
with Carol of those two characters
arguably I'd say Carol is the more
tragic one so I think that Beth would
get out in that scenario and Carol would
be the one to die it's a little early to
make guesses so those are just theories
right now no matter what the scenario
ends up being I don't think that she's
gonna go crazy like she's not gonna bite
anyone's neck out question number six
Cynthia as Maggie went crazy trying to
fight
Glenn but she hasn't mentioned Beth once
that we know of what's up with that yes
Emily can he address this on talking
dead she said uh you know I get it she's
got her boyfriend that she found and
she's just concentrating on trying to
stay alive I liked it the actress that
plays Beth is apologizing for Maggie if
they've gone this long without bagi
mentioning Beth I don't think that it's
gonna come up anytime soon I do think
it's possible that Abraham's group will
have a scene somewhere where Maggie will
find something that reminds her of Beth
and then she'll pause and think about it
but it might all be internalized
question number seven Mike asks what if
Rick knows the police officers in the
hospital yeah so Keene County was pretty
near in Atlanta so it's possible that he
knows some of those people there were
some people hypothesizing that this
person in this picture here is officer
Lerner in the fictional history that the
show created for her she's an original
character they didn't say anything about
being a sheriff in King County so I
don't think she's directly connected to
Rick I think they will draw some
parallels between her character and
Rick's character because they're both
officers of the law trying to do what
they think is right
even though I do think that officer
Lerner is a villain in the hospital the
twist is is that she's operating from a
very rational place they need order and
rules to survive they need resources
they need to preserve those she has a
system that she's created it kind of
works she's trying to maintain it I
think what we need to watch out for is
for her to completely snap during that
post-credit scene
she snapped a little bit but I think
that was just a momentary break or it
could be foreshadowing for I think it
would be a disservice to make the
character go completely nuts I think if
they did that it would just be another
version of the governor it would just be
them recycling old material it'd be like
another Woodbury question number eight
whose shoe asks how do they keep finding
so much food shouldn't it all be expired
by now so they're still working
generators giving power to the city
where their freezers with food in it I
don't really know what kind of
generators they have operating around
Atlanta but if they do have a nuclear
power plant nearby then they have power
indefinitely they just have to keep it
operational so in terms of food spoiling
they still have ways to preserve it and
there's the gerbils the gerbil meat was
just a callback to the meat at terminus
you know funky meat whenever he offered
it to Beth and sort of talking about it
I thought that might be where they're
getting all their meat like they're
breeding gerbils for me
question number nine Earvin to ask
what's going on with AMC and DirecTV so
they're having a carriage deal of
dispute and AMC is threatening to take
their channels off the air most of their
channels now all of them the same thing
happened last year with dish for those
that don't know this is really just a
United States thing so international
people shouldn't be affected by this and
anyone that does not have DirecTV
doesn't have to worry about it either
AMC and DirecTV haven't reached a
financial arrangement for renewing their
contract if you do have DirecTV though I
totally feel for you don't worry this
will probably be resolved fairly soon
question number 10 daily dose of me
asked do you think that NOAA feels bad
about leaving Beth behind I totally
think he'll feel bad I think whenever
they lead the charge to go back and get
her he'll be on that team from the
little we did see of him he seems like a
fairly positive person he doesn't seem
like a coward like you Jean or the
doctor I know a lot of you are asking me
about how long he's gonna be on the show
he's not a series regular but I do think
it's playing his contract if they want
to make him a series regular later as
far as I know though he's only going to
be in a couple episodes this season
thank you so much for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do I
think generally all just waiting to see
what is gonna happen with Carol and Beth
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner hunter Murdock you in the Amazon
giftcard just contact me on my channel
or somewhere on social like Facebook or
Twitter for details again next week's
episode is gonna be all about the DC
crew so be sure to subscribe to get my
video we'll find out what Abraham and
his moustache are doing so in case you
haven't seen it yet you can click here
for my episode 4 video and you can click
here for last week's episode 3 video
thank you so much for watching so it's
all high five and I'll see you guys
tonight